design constraints and new uh issues
that arise in sort of large scale
machine learning and data analysis and
then if you go back to your old
textbooks and dust them off you know
some old idea that is seemingly not
useful might be useful so who would have
thought that strauss's algorithm might
see the light of day now for
communication rather than computation
reasons but you know it looks like
that's the case so we'll see something
similar here
so there's been a lot of work on
randomized matrix algorithms
a lot of theoretical work and in the
last you know five or six or seven years
especially a lot of empirical work and
both in machine learning and data
analysis applications but also
high quality numerical implementations
and there's been a couple big big
successes for these ideas on single
machines in ram comparing for example to
l.a pack so the question is can these
ideas actually be implemented in large
scale settings meaning parallel and
distributed
and so the answer will turn out to be
yes and how do you do that and the i the
bottom line is use the same sort of
ideas
but you worry about uh communication and
not computation and you have to dust off
your old textbooks and uh and and uh
some old ideas will see the light of day
so
oh okay so with that in mind so um the
goal here is you know can you do large
scale vector space analytics by that i
mean if you go to a machine learning
meeting so nips or something you know
everything so to formulate in terms of
matrices
and that's very different than uh
databases where people think about the
data and you put them in a database just
the mental model of the data is very
different
and so the question is can you bridge
that gap so small scale and medium scale
it's much more common to model the data
by graphs and matrices which which
involve fairly sophisticated operations
like computing eigenvectors and
correlations
and that's very different than if you
really go large scale you're modeling
the data with flat tables and
and relational models logical operations
on the data so the question is
um
can you bridge that gap and do these
sort of matrix computations in in very
large scale settings and the answer is
you know not obviously yes right because
exactly computing eigenvectors and
correlations and so on is a fairly
subtle thing and requires all sorts of
communication to be exactly in exactly
as important orthogonal
and it's not obviously no because a
lesson from a lot of the random sampling
and random projection algorithms is that
if you get epsilon close and strong or
weak notions of epsilon
you can do that with very very few
samples
so
why randomize matrix algorithms in
particular so
to oversimplify a large
and detailed story i mean traditional
algorithms direct integrative methods
and so on designed to work uh basically
in ram
and uh the goal is to optimize flops
um they're not so well suited for
problems that are very very large
distributed parallel and that can mean
different things for different people in
different places when communication is
the bottleneck so you saw an example of
that in the previous talk and when you
have to access the data via passes
either physical or logical
so randomized matrix algorithms in a lot
of cases are faster if you're just
interested in better worst case theory
uh the randomization in a lot of cases
means is simpler to implement you know
making decisions about pivot rules is a
fairly complicated thing but if you
smudge stuff out a little bit inside the
algorithm a lot of those decisions will
become easier some cases they implicitly
regularize because the noise inside the
algorithm avoid some sort of overfitting
you can parallelize and make them more
scalable to a lot of large scale data
so again to oversimplify so traditional
algorithms you want to solve least
squares low rank you know so on and so
forth you can use direct methods like qr
and the svd and there's pros and cons
about high precision they're in l.a pack
but it might be hard to take advantage
of sparsity and do in parallel
distributed environments
there's iterative methods they have
typically have low cost per iteration or
fairly easy to implement but in general
you know it's hard to predict the number
of iterations because it depends on the
condition number
for l1 regression there's a bunch of
different methods it's in some sense
parallel this but you know the details
of differences linear programming
there's interior point you'll typically
use simplex or interior point methods
who uses the ellipsoid method in
practice right so we'll revisit that
dust off the textbooks relatedly squares
for sort of method so you know wide wide
range of algorithms for low rank
approximations on boil down to variance
of these so what i want to talk about
today is sort of a very simple
setup over constrained regression so if
you have this
a lot of the ideas will extend a low
rank approximation and a range of other
problems but just for today i'm going to
talk about over constrained regression
by which i mean the matrices are tall
and if the matrices are tall and m by n
m is large and is small
and you have
a matrix a and a vector b where b is
tall
in general there's not a solution ax
equals b
right yet any noise to the data you're
going to have a part of b sitting
outside the column space of a so the
goal is to find the best vector x such
that ax equals b and best can mean
different things so you can say minimize
the two norm
minimize the one norm minimize something
else
so let's let's call the lp norm you
wanna
you know the the minimize the p norm of
ax minus b and so what we want to find
is an approximate solution uh x hat
uh that's within one plus epsilon of the
optimal x
either on the uh
on the uh
objective or you can compare the two
vectors themselves
so p equals two is least square's
approximation very very widely used but
not so robust to outliers p equals one
is least absolute deviations
approximation right the problem gauss
sort of would have solved had he been
able to but he had to fall back to do
gaussian elimination basically so p
equals one of people's two you should
have in the back of your mind we'll be
talking about that so large scale um i
think there's gonna be two
uh situations here you know you have ram
and your memory um either go large scale
and you have shared memory a bunch of
processors or distributed memory and so
when we wrote this up into due diligence
these are the numbers we found they're
probably different now that it's a year
later but
you're going to go large scale and
you're going to have shared memory or
distributed memory
and we're tall so a x close to
b so let me spend three or four slides
talking about how you'd solve these
problems in ram and if you understand
the basic ideas the extensions to
parallel and distributed will be
relatively straightforward use the same
ideas
worry about communication not
computation and dust off the textbooks
so
um two important notions so i've tried
highlighted fortunately the red's
working today and so if you want to
ignore most of what's on the slide and
focus on the red focus on the red so
there's two ideas you need one is
something having to do with what i'll
call statistical leverage
so this is basically the non-uniformity
structure on the input that is that you
need to get a handle of to get a low
precision solution and the other
something i'll call the condition number
this is the non-uniformity structure on
the input that you need to get a handle
on to get a high precision solution so
leverage is about eigenvectors condition
number is about eigenvalues
the statistical leverage scores of a
matrix say that we're tall are the
diagonal elements of the projection
matrix onto the span of the columns
all right if you have left singular
vectors they're the euclidean norms of
the left singular vectors
to compute exactly they take as long as
solving the problem you can compute them
approximately faster but but the
structural property that defines low
precision solutions the condition number
think eigenvalues the l2 norm condition
number is the ratio of the max to the
min eigenvalue if you think of an
ellipsoid it's the aspect ratio of the
longest of the shortest direction
computing that takes time to the same as
computing the exact solution but it
gives you the non-uniformity structure
for high precision solutions all right
these are for the l2 norm
generalizations that are a little bit
noisier but generalizations will exist
to l1 and other sorts of problems
all right so the idea is that this
measures how well correlated the
singular vectors are with the canonical
basis or which constraints have the
largest influence on least squares fit
and this tells you something about the
aspect ratio of the quadratic well so if
you're going to do an iterative
algorithm you don't want that to be too
bad you want to precondition
so here's a meta algorithm that
will the same idea will apply for l1 and
l2 regression i'll describe it for l2
here
using the l2 leverage scores of a
say you have a black box to compute them
approximately or exactly or you've
uniformized them but for now just take
them as given using those l2 scores of a
construct an important sampling
distribution over the constraints
remember you're tall so it's over the
constraints
randomly sample a small number of
constraints according to that
distribution
small number of rows according to that
distribution
solve the sub problem
all right you're tall bias yourself
towards the outliers solve the sub
problem if you do that you get one plus
epsilon relative error approximation so
there's randomness in the sampling so
that's with probability one minus delta
but you get a relative error
approximation
all right two problems one it's the
running time is m times n squared
which is the time it takes to solve the
problem exactly
and in fact it's m times n squared
divided by epsilon and that's not bad if
epsilon's 0.1 but that is a problem of
epsilon 10 to the minus 10.
both of those problems can be overcome
how do you overcome it you can make this
meta algorithm fast in ram by doing one
of two things
either use a hadamard based or fourier
based random projection so you use a
hadamard based random projection
which basically involves rotating to a
random basis where those scores are
uniform
sample uniformly
or quickly compute approximation to
those scores
using a black box i'm not going to go
into detail but the black box the
running time of that is a hadamard based
projection and use those approximations
as your important sampling distribution
so
you're little of m n squared
i haven't taken care of the epsilon but
that actually works in theory and in
practice
and you can make this algorithm high
precision in ram by doing either of
those two things and rather than solving
the sub-problem use that as a
pre-conditioner
and call a traditional iterative
algorithm
all right and then your m n
log n log one over epsilon
not high dimension low dimension squared
but high dimension low dimension log low
dimension log one over epsilon you ask
how does this perform in practice so
this is blend and pick um avram and
toledo and at least one of them is in
the room and the other one's also at the
meeting
and so they evaluated this idea this
latter idea here
and there's a number of numerical issues
that i'm going to gloss over but the
bottom line is that randomized
algorithms will beat la pax direct dense
least squares solver by a large margin
on essentially any tall dense matrix so
this isn't some esoteric problem that
you know we've sort of defined and said
maybe a little bit better here what they
did here is take l a pack on head to
head and say that if you do a good
implementation non-trivial but good
non-trivial implementation these ideas
you're going to beat la pac which has
been you know the state of the art for a
couple decades and these results suggest
that these algorithms should be
incorporated into future versions of
lapac so this can be used gennaeus and
others have used this for dna snip
applications in these ideas
if you're going to do a thousand cross
validations on a matrix of size
5 000 or 10 000 by a million or so
that's not something that you're going
to be able to do in in matlab or easily
in ram but if you use these sorts of
ideas as part of that you can do that
so
bottom line is randomized major has a
big success story in high precision
scientific computing and lowercase l
large scale data applications can they
really be implemented in parallel
environments for capital l large scale
you know by which you mean terabytes a
parallel distributor to whatever
so the answer to that is what i'll spend
the rest of the talk talking on um
but we'll see that the same basic idea
over constrained you either want to
define some sort of notion of outliers
or transform the matrix such that those
outliers are uniformized in which case
you sample uniformly that will give you
a low precision solution
and if you iterate
and
iterating is different in l2 versus l1
notion of outliers is different than l2
and then l1 but in both cases if you
then iterate you can get a moderate to
high precision solution
and you can do that in parallel and
distribute environments and you don't
worry about hadamard based projections
that really beat on flops you can use
something else it's a little bit slower
but has better communication and other
sorts of properties all right
so let's talk about l2 regression
and think of this as shared memory so
there's we have a couple implementations
but mpi i think and then we'll talk
about l1 regression in sort of a hadoop
map-reduced style environment
here's lsrn and if you're familiar with
blend and pick think of blend and pick
uh with a gaussian projection on not a
hadamard you get slightly better
concentration properties and things and
we're able to get call a better iterator
basically but think blended pick
for parallel environments
so again remember we're tall
all right it's a tall regression problem
and we're going to rotate to a random
basis with the outlying scores the
leverage scores are uniformized
so choose an oversampling factor gamma
let's say gamma equals 2
and we're going to choose 2 times n the
low dimensions and 2 times n
constraints rows we could choose 3 times
n and exactly the details of the
concentration of the condition number
will depend on that gamma
generate a matrix of gaussian random
variables so random projection matrix
we're not doing a hadamard thing you
could but but this parallel lies
slightly more simply and we'll get
better concentration properties in the
eigenvalues here
compute a
hat is equal to g times a so do a random
projection so a is tall
and we're projecting down to something
that's still tall but much less tall
compute a's economy sized svd you had
sigma hat v-hat transpose and let's let
n be v-hat sigma inverse alternatively
you could do a qr there and let n be our
inverse
and then use that don't solve the sub
problem but use that as a preconditioner
so iteratively compute the min length
solution to this precondition problem
and call a black box to solve that
all right
so the gaussian random projection has
the best theoretical properties on
conditioning i'll put on the next note i
mean it can be generated particularly
fast it uses level three blasts
on dense matrices but it'll
automatically speed up on sparse
matrices and fast operators if you can
partition a in a particular way it still
works for the next or all reduce
operations so although it's slow
in theory in ram theory
in particular compared with quote fast
hadamard or fast johns and lindenstrasse
projections
in terms of flops it's going to give us
better communication
so an exact arithmetic we're going to
solve this exactly now we're not an
exact arithmetic we need to worry about
numerical issues but those we can take
care of
the distribution of the spectrums this
is one nice property of the gaussian
projections the distribution of the
spectrum of a times n the preconditioned
version of a
is going to be the same as that of the
pseudo inverse of a certain gaussian
matrix
independent of a
all right so we'll need to use an idea
from random matrix theory to control
that but it doesn't depend on the input
matrix
which is a very nice property actually
um the condition number is independent
of a
the condition number of the pre-process
thing is independent of the entries of a
and hence of the condition number of a
that's saying the same thing again
and so for any alpha we're going to have
that the probably the condition number
is close to 1 is going to be very high
as a function of
a certain parameter alpha right so think
of the condition number is 10. so if you
choose
gamma to be 2 so the number of samples
is 2 times the low dimension
kappa is less than 6 or 10. so the
condition number is 10 of the input of
the process problem
so lsrn we have implementation shared
memory um
c plus with a matlab interface if you're
not careful generating the random bits
is the most expensive thing so we had to
use a multi-threaded ziggurat random
number generator if you're familiar with
that
naive implementation of multi-threaded
sparse dense matrix multiplication we
also have a message passing
implementation in python single threaded
blasts for the matrix matrix and matrix
vector multiplies and multi-threaded
uh blast lapec for the svd so the
question is how do you do the iterations
and
if you know nothing else about iterative
methods you know conjugate gradient and
there's a million variants of conjugate
gradients so you can use that
but in
addition i've told you the condition
number is 10. we can control failure
probabilities and things so believe that
it's 10. and if i give you a promise
that the condition number is good
i can actually use a different method i
don't i can use conjugate gradient but i
don't have to i can use something else
and that's something else if you go off
and dust off your textbook something
called the chebative simulator method so
it turns out i had actually seen this
ten years ago but of course i didn't
remember it and so jean-ray manga
student who did this came back and said
well we can use chebychev's emulative
and so i asked what is that and it turns
out it was right there on my shelf and
in the book i had a mark next to it but
i had long since forgotten so dust off
the textbooks use chebychev's simulative
method instead of lsqrn so i'll say why
that is the case
so real word problems and corresponding
running times um
a bunch of real data sets let me not go
into the details we have an order of
magnitude on the size here so we're
going to see an order of magnitude
variance on the size
um
the matlab routine is not going to take
advantage of sparsity so this is running
time so these numbers are larger than
say those
and we have an order of magnitude on the
size some of these are going to be
ranked efficient so full rank but some
of these will be rank deficient
so
this particular
you know version lap doesn't take
advantage of sparsity matlab's blacks
backslash calls a bunch of different
things depending on the matrix
it may not give the mid-length solution
to rank-deficient or under-determined
problems but you know we can still use
it it does well in a lot of cases
blend and pick in some cases doesn't
apply because of the rank deficiency
although you can modify it to take care
of that
or runs out of memory
so ls rn's running times are basically
determined by the problem size you have
lapak
matlab blend and pick blend picks
actually does well in a lot of cases so
these problems are chosen to be ranked
efficient or
sparse or parallel
this is ram sorry where that would have
problems so lsrn does well on all those
running times and the scaling is not bad
so the relevant thing about iterating is
if you're going to iterate with lsqr and
lsqr is basically conjugate gradients um
on the normal equations but done done
the right way
and this goes back 30 years so the
relevant code snippet from python here
is that there's an all reduce here and
an all reduce here so there's going to
be two matrix vector multiplications per
iteration and two cluster-wide
synchronizations
and so the advantage of typical
conjugated iterative methods is they're
just going to keep iterating forever and
if the condition number is bad it'll
take a lot more steps but it'll just
keep iterating it's not going to fail
terribly
and this will work alternatively because
i've promised you that the condition
number is 10 or better
you can use an iterative method
that will fail terribly if the condition
number is bad but will succeed if the
condition number is good in particular
the conjugate the chebychev simulative
method and that is the same computation
two matrix vector multiplications but
one cluster-wide synchronization one
i'll reduce here all right so because we
use the projection with good
concentration we get strong control in
the condition numbers we're able to use
an iterative method that has better
communication properties
and so lsrn with chebychev simulative
this is on an amazon ec2 cluster i think
there's uh
11
nodes here i think
um chebychev's simulator has an lsqr in
order oh i have it right here uh two to
20. chebychev's ammunitive and lsqr um
the number of iterations is slightly
more actually for the chebychev semitive
method each iteration is much faster and
so in total the running times um
are going to be slightly better for the
chebychev simulative method here but
both will work if you're willing to pay
that
factor of 2 but it's not quite a factor
of 2 because each iteration is a little
bit faster so both of these will work
on highly over determined highly
underdetermined problems here in a
parallel environments out on amazon's
ec2 we could get larger but then it gets
tricky because we don't have control
over the cluster that we're constructing
all right so let me um
tell you how similar ideas can be used
to solve l1 regression so using these
ideas a lot of these
um will extend to low rank so you want
to do lease you want to do low rank
matrix approximations pca svd latent
factor models and so on
and so you can use these ideas uh we
haven't done that in the parallel case
but other people and then we've done
some of the theory some of the some of
the implementations in in ram
so let me talk about an extension to l1
regression least absolute deviations
because there are a lot of new ideas
enter because you're dealing basically
with a convex problem not an eigenvector
problem
so
if someone's interested in the details
talk to me afterwards because there's a
lot of details that i'm going to be
glossing over here but at ten thousand
feet the rough idea is that
everything i've been describing will
generalize all right it will generalize
in in complicated ways and it's not as
nice it'll generalize messily it's not
as nice as l2 but in particular
you can define a notion of an l1
well-conditioned basis right an
orthogonal matrix is nice for l2 because
the norm is not too large for an
orthogonal matrix if you have a
rectangular orthogonal matrix the
forbenius norm say is the low dimension
not the high dimension and because if
you multiply that matrix times a vector
you don't stretch it it's a rotation so
you can define a you know alpha beta two
parameters to say for l one if the
the norm of the matrix is not too large
and if that matrix applied to a vector
does not stretch or shrink that vector
too much parameterized by alpha and beta
it's going to be well conditioned
you can define these l1 outlying scores
l1 leverage scores to be the row norms
of a well conditioned basis and you can
define the l1
a notion of l1 conditioning so there's
not as much structure here as in l2 so
you shouldn't think that all the ideas
from l2 extend here but these particular
ones to control the
the computations the way i described it
do
so the meta algorithm is using an l1
well condition basis construct important
sampling distribution
randomly solve the sub problem randomly
solve a small number of rows sample
small number of rows to construct a sub
problem
solve the l1 regression sub problem
all right
as with l2 regression you can make this
algorithm much faster in ram either by
approximating these l1 leverage scores
or by performing i'll call it an l1
projection this was actually not
something that was practical until solar
and woodruff came up with the notion of
a koshi transform and then you can also
do a hadamard version of that to get a
fast koshi transform but the solon
woodruff the koshi transform actually
does pretty well
so i'll call an l1 projection and it's
not a projection but a soft sense of the
word to uniformize those scores
approximately and if you do that you can
sample uniformly in that rotated space
and you can make this algorithm work at
higher precision in ram at a larger
scale by coupling with an iterative
algorithm which isn't going to be
conjugate gradient because we're not
solving eigenvectors but it'll be
something different
so um you can condition in a couple ways
basically you can you want to say that
when you take pi times a pi is your
koshi
projection matrix pi times a and look at
the norms of that you're not within one
plus epsilon of the norms of the
original problem which was you'd get
from johnson lindenstrasse and gaussian
projections
um and my apologies i've just changed
letters on you now are n by d but you
know you're something polynomial in the
low dimensions you're not one plus
epsilon but you're close you know your
factor of 100
and that will manifest itself in the
condition number which manifests itself
in the number of iterations so you can
construct this pi and then don't do one
of two things either you can do a qr on
it and that's not a gaussian that's a
koshi projection so qr is doing
something a little bit strange that's
not quite as unitarily invariant or you
can condition via an ellipsoid rounding
method so those are two black boxes
and there's a bunch of trade-offs so you
can use the original slokoshi fast coast
ellipsoid rounding fast ellipsoid
rounding and then a bunch of sparse
versions of these koshi's trade-offs in
running time in general as you go down
here the running times get better
there's some exceptions to that and in
general the condition numbers get worse
so there's a trade-off there
and
spc3 is a particular method that is not
optimal by running time and is not
optimal by condition number it's a
little bit sub-optimal on both of those
but that's the one that actually
performs best because there's a
trade-off there
so if you use this i'll show on the next
slide you know you get a reasonably good
low precision solution and then we need
to iterate and so how do you iterate and
so remember the issue before is that you
don't want the number of iterations to
be the samples to be 1 over epsilon you
want it to be log of 1 over epsilon and
so if you use a subgradient method due
to clarkson the number of passes is
something divided by epsilon squared if
you use a gradient method due to an
ester of its number passes something
divided by epsilon the first thing we
found to get this to work and
implemented was a variant of the
ellipsoid method which is something
times log of one over epsilon and then
we found the randomized interior point
cutting plane method having to do with
inscribed
ellipsoids slightly better still log of
one over epsilon
extra work per round n to the three
halves or into the fourths
all right but if we're in a parallel or
sorry a distributed environment think of
that as free and i'll say what i mean by
free
so we have a bunch of data sets in each
of time let me not describe the details
of the data sets but a bunch of real and
synthetic data sets to illustrate where
the method should work well and where it
should fail
um you can map this to mapreduce no pun
intended basically by not thinking about
his ram and pulling out a random sample
but you know defining key value pairs so
for each row of a to find a probability
to be basically the l1 leverage scores
and then for each k emit a key which is
that row index and the value is that row
were scaled so that's your key and your
value at the map phase reducer collects
all the row vectors associated with the
key assembles matrix ak and solve that
sub problem with the black box
multiple subsampled solutions can be
computed in a single pass
so this is um
the low precision solutions
um
the matrices of our size something on
the order of a billion by we have a
bunch of different things but you order
a billion by 150 or 100 so let's say
um so i'm not going to go into the
details of these numbers but these
basically say you can get say one one
digit maybe two digits of precision with
with the low precision solution find the
outliers or do the caution projection
solve the sub problem
so you want to iterate to get three or
four five digits so let's do a method of
inscribed ellipsoids so this is
basically think of this as a bisection
method in higher dimensions we're going
to do this as i said because it's the
smallest number of iterations you can
get a very good initialization using a
whole bunch of sub-sampled solutions and
you can do multiple queries per
iteration
so basically at each iteration we need
to compute a function value and a
gradient or sub gradient and then you're
going to use all these solutions to
either construct the initial condition
or to iterate
so how to compute function value and
grading in a single pass so you can do a
single query which just to give you the
equation it looks something like this or
you can do multiple queries which is not
a matrix vector multiply but a matrix
matrix multiply
if you can compute
one function value and one gradient on a
representative size
it'll take 282 seconds
if you do this a factor of 100 times
more 100 function values 100 gradients
it takes 320 seconds so that's what i
mean when i say the computation's free i
mean you're doing a fact of 100 more
work and it takes almost no more clock
time
the y axis here you probably can't read
but this is as a function of the number
of iterations
uh if you do a very good initial guess
you get a couple orders of magnitude
improvement and then if you do the smart
stuff at each iteration you're a little
bit better so what this says is that if
you just use the method of inscribed
ellipsoids
um with multiple queries uh with a bad
initial guess you get something you
could
improve on the order of 50 or 100
iterations if you come up with a good
initial guess the y axis here is 10 to
the minus 4 10 to the minus 5 and you
literate so this is on a smaller problem
in ram ten to the six by twenty uh that
should be a hundred fifty so we're at
ability you know a couple billion by a
hundred and fifty
um good initial guess puts you down at
ten to the minus two which is two or
three well between ten minus three and
ten minus two or three digits of
precision so even at the first initial
guess which is think in mapreduce you
have three passes over the date or four
depending on how you set up the sampling
probabilities and you can iterate to 30
iterations and you're going to get 10 to
the minus i can't even read that i think
it's in the minus six or five
so um so with that let me wrap up
randomized regression algorithms in
parallel and distributed environments
for least squares least absolute
deviations is a bunch of extensions
and the idea is
do a random projection to uniformize the
non-uniformity structure and then
worry about communication and not
computations you might have to use a
chebychev semi-iterative method rather
than a conjugate gradient you might have
to use a method of inscribed ellipsoids
to get moderate precision rather than an
interior point method which is going to
require lots of dot products and
communication
so um here's two examples that are sort
of very basic problems of uh
l1 and l2 least squares leads to
absolute deviations that underlie a huge
huge range of things and
there's two data points that we can
implement and evaluate these things in
very large scale
parallel and distributed settings with
that let me wrap up